[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay cool
[Music]
what's going on you guys
gaming out here coming out to another
video we're gonna be talking about the
past present and future of gaming you
guys know how it is you guys know
the same man
hustle unfortunately had some stuff he
had to do for for life you know life
comes first man we always gonna have
life come first so i went out and i got
gaming forte what's going on gaming for
today
what up though bro um i thought you
almost forgot who i was like what my
name was i gotta have the there's like
dramatics
he was preaching man it was like i was
like he reaching for like what's his
name
nah man it's good to be here man it's uh
i know i missed a couple weeks ago when
you had slo-mo which was an amazing show
by the way yeah actually
said that he he was some people said in
the chat he was their favorite guest
well listen man slow-mo is literally the
backbone of dps podcast so you know
i'm just a stand-in but
we're gonna have to eventually uh come
together and do that dps and uh
and and um dps and the attic show man
got to get you and we do you hustle and
slo-mo all in the same show
so all right man there's gonna be a lot
of stuff going on when that happens
here's what's going on with the chat not
the chat the the title i haven't changed
yet but we're going to change the order
around because there are a couple things
i feel like we do need to address that's
in these gaming streets right now
so
let's talk about
stuff when it comes to how
the industry should
impact on what buggy games are and then
i also want to talk about review scores
and
exactly how the reviewing system is i
you know what i need to do for i need to
get like jeff grubb on here or someone
one day to like really go over
that that kind of aspect what's funny is
i was i was looking through tick tock
forte and there was um some dude like a
news channel kind of what we do on
youtube he does on tick tock so i was
thinking i should start making videos
of just talking [ __ ] on tick tock like
but you know i'm trying to be a better
addict man trying to that sounded really
bad trying to be a better addict but
okay i've tried to be a better person
trying to be a better person so we're
not going to do that but all right so
we're going to talk about that we do
have some xbox doing good in japan they
actually opened up wire in xbox you know
that might not seem like a huge thing to
to people in the chat
but that is pretty big over there
because it shows commitment it shows
that you're going to be
in some way shape or form prioritizing
the viewership in the consumer base over
there then we're gonna talk about the
witch queen
you know me and uh forte are
our destiny addicts we're gonna be
talking about that then we're gonna end
it all off with the elden ring vs
horizon fiasco
devastation that's going on on twitter
man people are comparing these two games
and they're doing it very harshly so
what do you want to talk about first
forte for what what's something that
interests you first oh man do you do you
want to just get into like all the smoke
on um i feel like we should i feel like
we should save the horizon thing you
want to save the smoke okay well let's
let's talk well you know this is you
know the iron lords you know and the
attic show and myself you know we're
we're considering you know xbox and
stuff like that you know people think
that we we only love xbox but we love
all platforms so let's let's let's
tackle you know
xbox you know japan and everything let's
get let's get let's get there let's get
everybody's appetite wet first all right
so for those of you that know there is
this
website called xbox wire it's pretty
much like a weekly
thing that they do they might do it
monthly i don't know but they do what
they're it's their blog oh their blogs
they got a blog that they really go over
you know what's new with xbox and it's
never really been anywhere else like
because for the most part the majority
of the world speaks english so they
always keep it in english i it do they
got like any other ones like is that
like a german one or anything or is it
literally mainly just english no it's
just it's mainly just english but
microsoft actually surprising i almost
made a video about this forte i came
this close to making a video about this
but i had so many videos i could make
this seemed like something that was
small but i can make a small video into
something great
but so i was i was looking at this and i
was like look people might not see
this being a big deal but this shows
like i said this shows the japanese
consumer and the japanese market in
general because i'm sure there's a lot
of developers of publishers over there
that feel like microsoft doesn't take
them seriously microsoft doesn't take
that market seriously but they're doing
something special over there by
doing a blog and not to mention
they're providing jobs over there
because it's not like like anyone over
here is doing that like it's all
native really ran over there and they're
doing a blog pretty much i don't know if
it's weekly or monthly but they're going
to be going above and beyond for the
japanese consumer base because phil
spencer has said for the longest time
that i
want
to get better results over there and he
was a presence basically yeah and this
this is this is so this is a good
movement you guys know i am with the
japanese market so when you first heard
this forte what was your first thought
process besides let's make a video
let's make a video no i
this is something that
not only
microsoft has been trying to crack for
the last few years not even last few
years for like the last few generations
you know trying to solve the whole
xbox in japan um situation they didn't
have you know they want to grow the
ecosystem and stuff like that um i just
think this is a good move just because
they've always it's like
people thought they gave up on it a long
time ago like it's it's it's like some
people feel like it's like an
afterthought at this point like you only
show how many a hundred thousand units
of the xbox one over in japan like
that's putrid but
also the japan marketplace has changed
drastically over the course of not even
the last generation but just
over the last
four or five years
you know nintendo switch is the most
dominating system over there when it
comes to home consoles
but mobile has become such a big part of
the ecosystem over there so not only
just getting xbox's presence there in
just consoles but they want to get the
name out there more just so
when uh things like xcloud really truly
take off
they have a name inside that ecosystem
that you don't have to have a system in
your house you can have you can still be
a part of our ecosystem so the system is
something that they want to use to
bridge that gap but the longer play is
getting people on their phones where
they but they predominantly commute the
most and that's where xbox is looking at
the biggest push at right there um but
let's not kill ourselves xbox they are
moving in the direct in the correct
direction and they're just been
constantly
[Music]
evolving themselves
yeah they're just but they always try to
evolve themselves when it comes to
trying to cater to that marketplace you
know they know what they're doing over
in america you know some people probably
say they don't but
for the most part they do they do pretty
pretty well this is their number one
market over here it's where they
struggle is in the worldwide appeal
that's why everybody can't say it
microsoft would never be sony because
sony had worldwide appeal and this is
why because places like over europe or
in the uk or places where the stronghold
isn't the strongest for xbox
it's really no my share there so how do
you get mineshare there well if you
can't sell a system
you get the name out there some other
way and i do think game pass is the
bigger play
but um phil spencer spends a lot of time
in japan like i think he's visits there
is more than anywhere else in the
country
or in the world uh so this is just par
for the course for him and i think
i think phil spencer will not retire
as head of xbox until he finds a way to
crack that egg i think that's i think
that's his
his uh his coup de gras right there
japan
yeah and to be honest with you man like
phil spencer i will say you know i used
to be a skeptic of phil spencer i think
everyone used to it's just like you know
we we want to see results we don't want
to keep hearing promises it's kind of
like the presidency right we want to
hear we don't see votes we don't care
what you say you're going to do but one
thing i will say about phil spencer is
he came out and he said what he's gonna
work on hardware services and games he
said that like three or four years ago
in that order too literally that order
he came out the xbox series of the xbox
one x as the hardware because he wanted
to get rid of that power narrative
because they were getting butchered back
then because of it
then he worked on services now
regardless if
services was always going to be a thing
in terms of game pass i don't know if
that was always on the tables or
something that came out there
during the talks of the services
he came out with with the services you
know he dropped x he dropped uh games uh
the paywall on a lot of things he
dropped the paywall on was that the uh
on the free-to-play games and it was
sure it took them a little bit but they
did it man they did it that's all that
matters we got that took care of and
then he said games
and people always used to make fun of
him why are you doing hard work why are
you doing services we want to see games
and then
the money that they spend it's like the
other ones they are spending twice as
much on this
they they bought bethesda they but
they're buying activision right now they
bought multiple studios that have no
no relations to any type of publisher so
we can honestly say that phil spencer
might go down as one of the best
executives for a gaming company ever
because he took i wouldn't say
that xbox was on life support back then
but it was definitely one trip away from
being on life support it was like you
know when you're playing destiny forte
it's red and you know if you get hit one
time it's a rap like that's where he was
and he went to the best rock he possibly
could and didn't get shot again and he
was able to regenerate that shield and
then he came out with the xbox one x and
then he came out with the services known
as game pass and now he's coming out
with all of these games now look it's
debatable i personally feel like you
can't really say that a game is just
gonna start producing bad stuff but i
understand if people feel that way they
need to see it and i've always been very
vocal when it comes to stuff like that
if you feel like you need to wait to see
these games wait to see these games you
don't have to
you know take their word for it you
don't have to buy an xbox series x
and with stuff like the mobile app and
uh you know xcloud and game pass
ultimate they'll have more access to
japan they'll have more access to places
in china that still allow any form of of
gaming going on and i think that's
that's the key thing here they want to
build that viewership in japan because
they know sooner or later that x-cloud's
going to be exactly where they need it
to be and that's how they're going to
infiltrate the japan markets i don't
think they're dealing with consoles
because playstation can't even do it
with consoles and if playstation can't
do it with consoles then what makes you
think xbox gonna be able to do it look
at the nintendo switch is doing
fantastic because of the uh nintendo's
doing great because of the nintendo
switch and well part of that reason is
like look people have the option to hook
that up to a tv if they want to and if
they don't want to hook up to a tv all
they do is play it in the handheld and i
i think it's it's interesting man it's
interesting where they're going to go
with this i i've always been very vocal
forte you know me about i probably have
50 60 videos talking about i want better
results in japan and sure this is a good
way i see of of getting people's
mindsets to doing better in japan like
you know
i think there was a developer that said
look like one of the reasons that where
we don't take america seriously is
because we don't see the marketing being
pushed here we don't see
your own consoles being here we don't
see none of that you know sure some of
that might be the retailers there that
aren't putting xbox in good positions
like i'm sure being at gamestop you
could you know you know that you know
positioning is key if you're at the
front of the store you have a better
chance of selling stuff to being at the
back of the store so right
i don't know how retailers do it back
there but i'm sure that could be a
significant part in what's going on over
there in terms of retail but forte what
happens if you don't sell nothing what
do you do with that product
well i it literally sits there and drops
in price um because people don't
understand the whole thing about cost of
goods
uh it's just like if we buy something
from a customer and then we say we pay
we give you 30 for a game that
sp okay elder ring that i just got
traded in yesterday shout out to the
tweet that i did yesterday we paid
somebody very well
right we we traded we gave that person
33 dollars and store credit for it and
um now if that game sits on our shelf
for
two weeks and the price drops on it
instead of you know selling it at 54
dollars they're only gonna sell it
probably for 47 meaning they lost some
of the profit that they would have sold
on that on that game if if they don't
sell it right away it's the same thing
with anything else the reason um
nintendo does so well
they don't drop prices on stuff and
that's why they consistently stay in the
black because they don't ever really
drop their prices set for certain times
of the year compared to like some of
these aaa games
that's why they always tell you like
call of duty the biggest window for call
of duty is right when it releases
because they sell the majority of their
games they'll still sell consistently
throughout the year but they sell the
majority of the bulk at the beginning
horizon forbidden west sales for
predominantly the most in the beginning
and like god award like in 2018. three
million in the first of what was it
three million the first eight days or
something like that
it that was all at the very very
beginning and then it still just tapers
off after that and then you got people
like dave's gone developers coming out
talking about buying games at full price
because
the majority of those sales happen when
the game was on sale versus the game
being at a 60 dollar price so
it's it's very impactful when um things
don't sell when you first get them
sometimes it just comes down to just
consumerism and stuff and word of mouth
circulating on certain games and things
like that and then you see people like
kind of gravitated to it at that point
but to answer the question just bluntly
it's like it's not good to have your
stuff sitting on the shelf at that point
you're losing money the more it's
sitting there
what i was really pointing towards is
these japanese retailers like you know
it's easy to blame them for stuff like
this and i do think that maybe
they're not going to sell xbox well
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
like you you're not going to buy masses
massive amounts of inventory for
something that you're not going to sell
on the sale so you know
maybe they can do marketing better stuff
here because i know in the states and
other places the world like xbox
playstation they got representatives
that go to stores and they they make
sure that you know their brands being
represented correctly at these places i
don't know if that's being done in japan
with xbox if it is maybe microsoft
should work on that but it's like at the
end of the day like it's like i've
always stayed forte you know i've been
very vocal about this
they have plenty of western gains for
the western market that appeal to that
to play in xbox
they don't really have nothing on on the
japanese market eastern type of games
and that's what they need like you can't
go
to places like japan with no japan like
games nothing like over there you don't
got capcom making you anything you don't
got from software making you anything
you don't got anyone over there making
you anything and expect people over
there to purchase your platform
that's one of the reasons that sony was
so successful last generation because
they were always let's get this persona
5. like they focused on the western
market but they made sure the eastern
market was fine too that's how you build
water pill and until you've come out of
your shell and make sure that you have
genres for every type of gamer and for
every type of
place around the world you're never
going to have a war to pill
yeah but you you know
let's be for real
the world
sony
i mean it was situ it was it it was
planned i won't i won't take that away
from him
but
playstation
truly took off like playstation one
amazing like
gangbusters it was great playstation 2
put them on a map
playstation 2
got on the map because of one thing it
wasn't it was games
but the mass appeal came from the name
because it was the first thing first
time that a dvd player was included into
a console let's be for real here the
reason playstation 2
is so renowned and so so much is because
it did what the wii did back in 2007
people that
didn't even play games bought that
system
they bought it for i mean at the time i
think even the quote-unquote high-end
sony dvd player that was standalone was
a thousand dollars samsung thousand
dollars you can get a comparable one in
the little box well ps2 wasn't a little
box at the time when it came out but in
the box for four hundred dollars or it
was 350 i can't remember exactly how
many might have been 2.99 but it might
have been 399. but that was the reason
it did well so but then what they did
was they took that existing user base
and celebrated it by giving them amazing
games
and i believe xboxes was heading in that
direction
with the 360 and then they kind of fell
off the wagon
in 2010
when they stopped producing first party
games you know games like gears of war
halo was halo was still coming but like
it was like the old that's where the
whole formula of halogens and forza came
from because between literally 2007 and
2011 that's the only new ips we got and
they were just pretty much just spending
money on third-party exclusives and
stuff which was good too
but
sony just kept on iterating on their ips
and stuff you know knew i they didn't
hold any developer to just what you some
people don't even realize jack and
daxter is a freaking naughty dog gay
it's a naughty dog like you would never
even know that jackie baxter like like
who made jack and dax you have to go
look it up and you'll be like naughty
dog made this but compared to what we
know of naughty dog now two drastic
contrasts and type of video game making
and stuff so that's where saudi grew
they they found a way to penetrate the
market by giving people something that
they wanted that they didn't know they
wanted and then they just
eat down on that ecosystem by bringing
more and more games to that platform and
getting people in love with the platform
and then that's where the worldwide
appeal comes from
yeah and i definitely that that's
decades of
nurturing the entire thing but like what
i was really important for fortes like
if you don't start now you're never
gonna start it like you know you got to
start building these blocks so when it
is time to build that giant castle
around the world you can build it but if
you never put if you only have part of
the foundation in america but you don't
have it anywhere else you know it's
going to tip over because there's no way
to hold it on the rest of the world so
you know is microsoft have us does
microsoft have a headquarters in japan i
don't know maybe i don't think they they
probably have something there but
nothing like sony has here
yeah well i mean sony's worldwide
headquarters is here in america yeah
sony kind of low-key has one away from
the eastern influence sure they're still
there but i think that's like for
appearances suppose uh appearances like
personal purposes like i don't think
like i don't think they'll ever abandon
the japanese market but i don't i think
they're done making those games like i
think they would rather team up with
like atlas to make the next persona on
their platform i because that's the
reason they shut down uh japan studio
because i don't think they they're
interested in making that kind of those
games anymore it's more beneficial more
cost effective to just buy timed
exclusives like final fantasy
and persona than it is to create a
studio manager studio and fund a studio
to make a game that might or might not
hit
nope you're right i agree all right all
right so
let's talk about the review process the
right process we ain't gonna go too much
into this because i know it has a lot to
do with eldon ring and horizon and i
know i've stated that the review process
needs a lot of work so
right now forte i got one question for
you one question only
should you beat a game in its entirety
before you review that game
yes if you want to be taken serious
long term at least
if you are a type of person that
are just trying to get
different okay so if you just want to
get information out about a game that's
what impressions are for that's what um
that's what j call review in progress is
for
but when you throw the word review on a
screen
that needs to be encompassing of the
whole game it needs to be the experience
from beginning to end from a to b
you know that's why
you see reviewer like that's why you see
review in progress for stuff like
destiny where it's a long-term game uh
that's why you see like with shout out
to the homeboy bg where he did his video
it wasn't called the reviewers call his
impressions his thoughts
that's more people put review on
something because they know that's going
to be what catches the algorithm let's
be for real it's like i said in a party
when's the last time forte you saw in
your chat well besides maybe destiny
because we're used to reviewing progress
on destiny
was the last time you saw a review in
progress and you clicked that link
you didn't it's just
like wake me went wake me when all the
content when all the uh when
everything's out and i can know what the
hell
that's the biggest thing
is people
don't like see i'm in this thing right
here because i'm reviewing
the witch queen for the iop channel and
i was sitting here thinking do i review
just the story and put just story do i
just wait three or four days and review
the raid with it because the raid is
definitely part of the story so i was
like you know what i would i already
have a i already have a script and
everything forte but i pushed it back
i'm like look we're we're out of the
window anyway so it's like we get some
views but nothing drastic but saturday
people are gonna be searching
the raid and i'll just i'll put whatever
the raid name is i'll put witch queen
slash
whatever the raids called i think they
already have a name for it but whatever
the rates call review and then you know
put like uh like some kind of indication
and then like playstation 5 and xbox
series x and pc or whatever i'll have to
you know i'll have to i'll have to wing
it man i'll have to wing it but
i you'll be fine i've always felt like
when it comes to reviews like you got to
make sure that you play the game like
there's just no way around it like
it it's one of those things like
mr maddie plays i respect him so much
more because it's so
easy us as content creators we know it
is so easy
to want to get in on that day one wave
it is so easy
you will get caught up in there so fast
like you and then before you know it
like you your your mindset's like man i
need these i need this traction i need
the growth i need the you know a lot of
people do it for financial reasons which
is perfectly fine and they're like i
need that money so they do it and then
they get backlash because they did it
and when i say for the chat it's easy
you have no idea
how much of a difference your viewership
is going to be day one then it is day
seven it's not even remotely close it's
easy to wanna be this day one regardless
the consequences you might have it's
better to be here than it is here
this but at the end of the day it's
integrity that's in the middle
like do you care more about the name of
you your brand and you as an individual
than the money that's literally
different
i agree
i personally look obviously money's
great but at the end of the day
obviously
for the long term if no one takes you
seriously it might even be just five ten
percent of the people watching you that
might stop like you know actually go
into your review but that's five ten
percent throughout the next five to ten
years
is massive imagine what happens in these
parties when you and out there oh you
know this individual didn't beat the
game this individual didn't beat the
game that one didn't beat the game
it's word of mouth it's like video games
when you keep buying and buying and
buying it's it's better for you to just
go ahead and take that hit but
what we need to talk about too forte
is
the ridiculous
industry that we cover and how they
handle these review things there will be
developers and i know this has happened
that was that they know their game is is
is horrible and they'll send their game
the day
of the review or the day before the
reviews embargo lives because they know
that a they're either going to sit there
know like that and beat it and review it
or b they're going to review it and not
beat it and probably play five or six
hours and review it and they're not
going to really get a whole sense of the
whole game that's what needs to be
corrected look i do put a lot of
responsibility on the reviews but at the
same time the reviewers but at the same
time it's like i said a lot of these
people are doing this this
that's a job they don't have another job
so they have this weird sensation that
look i get it you guys are upset because
i didn't beat the game but at the end of
the day
the website that i cover for
they don't care about your morals they
want their clicks or i have to find a
new job so i understand that but then i
look at influences like acg and i i
don't like using acg as like the the
definition because
he's always the exception
like right acg makes sure he plays his
games and if he doesn't he's always very
vocal and transparent and and that's why
i don't like using him as a as as the
center focus because not everyone has
the dedication acg has like you know
jake balabino puts mad times into this
like to me if you're seeing people do it
why can't other people do it you know
what i'm saying forte like like a lot of
these people
me and you might have excuses why we
can't have stuff day one because we have
jobs and stuff but when you're doing it
full time do you think that takes away
that excuse that people use why i didn't
have time if you had
like three or four days let's say you
got something three days before release
which i think a week is is good a week
you should be able to easily do it
unless it's like a massive game but most
games aren't that massive most games are
realistically
10 to 15 hours long in the campaign and
what's funny is like not every game is
held in ring
by far not every game's evil ring but do
you think that's a realistic approach to
ask someone you got three or four days
you got 20 hours a 20-hour campaign and
keep in mind they're getting paid decent
money too it's not like a lot of these
people are getting paid like pebbles
they're not right but do you think that
you know
it should be expected for them to to
low-key crunch that's what they're doing
they're crunching like do you think that
should be an explanati uh an expectation
uh it should be you and then okay so
addy let me ask you a question why are
you doing a review
for destiny witch queen
because
i felt like the viewers would want our
opinions on which queen
why do you do reviews on other other
stuff on just anything in general oh
it's it's definitely the traction i'm
trying trying to grow
trying to grow try everybody's trying to
grow trying to get uh our videos and
parts of the internet that it's not
there trying to get our videos and
communities that we ain't into like
that's clearly the objective on everyone
so yeah exactly and my thing and it's uh
and
those those the growth what comes with
the growth comes monetary gains and
stuff
i feel like
if you tr it's just like a job
if you want to get paid 50 000 or 100
000 or a hundred fifty thousand dollars
a year
what are you gonna do to do it
are you going to go out if if if uh if
gorilla gives me a code
and says we want you to review this game
for horizon forbidden wes
and they say unfortunately we ran like
they say well we want to send you this
code because we really like your channel
unfortunately we couldn't get you an
early code but we can get you one three
or four days before the game comes out
all right i'm at a disadvantage because
everybody else probably had this for a
week but guess what i'm gonna do if i
truly want to grow
i'm gonna do everything in my power over
the next four days
to binge this game to the point where
you i'm gonna know everything about it
before i even before i even start
formulating my thoughts but then you
don't even have to get your review on
day one that's a whole nother thing i
think people don't really think about
too
by any means you don't i know me i have
a 48-hour rule if you can get reviews
out within 48 hours you have a way
better chance of getting now we talking
two to three weeks you probably don't
even make the video when did elderling
come my other ring came out on friday
people think okay so the reviews came
out on thursday
i have a video right now in eldon ring
doing numbers right now and i posted
yesterday so it's not like it was day
one it's not even a review here's the
thing that people don't realize just
because you don't do a review does not
mean you can't have coverage on that
game that's why you see people doing the
what i've learned about that's why you
see people doing that you know what you
should do beginner builds there's so
much content you can make on games it's
not just a review i made a rev i made a
video about elder ring that has nothing
to do with elder ring it's just the
practices that from software made that
was pretty much saying and companies
like square enix
when they have a hiccup and they don't
have cells they re-amp the entire
the entire game play and you got
companies like from software that's like
we're gonna take our foundation we're
gonna keep building and building and
building until we make a game like eldon
ring and that's what the video is about
nothing to do with elder ring just use
an elder ring as a catalyst doing doing
numbers
yep and the biggest thing i would try to
tell people is just because
it's a review date that you can put it
out like i said you don't have to do
that
you can go the complete other way you
can say okay i got the game at the same
time as everybody else but i'm not ready
to do my reviews not ready but when
people are dropping reviews on the games
you can like literally talk about my
first 10 out of my experience in the
first 10 hours of elder ring you can
literally put a video i'll say how my
experience at eldon ring was that's
exactly what mr maddie plays did and
that's why i respect him because he put
yeah 50 he did a 50 hour i think he said
80 50 or 80 i think it was well i think
how many hours it was maddie knew i
can't realistically beat this game in a
certain amount of time he posted out
there look here's my experience with x
amount of hours and then
he was transparent he explained he
didn't beat the game and his viewership
was still fine because
people are going to value especially
reviews when it comes reviews a lot of
people
expect integrity out of you and once you
lose that that's when you start
like that's when the viewership goes up
and down because people don't know what
to trust you about when it comes to
stuff like reviews that's the number one
thing that you cannot lose is in the
integrity that what you say comes out of
your mouth cannot be
influenced whatsoever
yeah i didn't listen to maddie's on it
but i can guarantee you because i did
see the thumbnail for 50 hours it was
like 50 or 80 like you said it played
but i guarantee you the one thing he did
doing that that that impressions of his
50 or whatever hours he probably put in
there saying and when i do get my full
guide my full review out i will you know
i will let you guys know so he probably
even put a date on when he will have his
review out but if he has thoughts on 50
hours of the game he probably already
has an idea of what window his review is
going to come out he said you know and
if you want to know my whole complete
story around what this game is in my
review check it out this friday because
he probably said next friday my review
will be out so not only is he getting
content out on day one he's funneling
people the content on another day when
they could kind of expect it and he
could do it on his own terms versus
having to do it by from software's terms
of getting the game out and i think you
know people just want to chase after the
money because that's what this truly is
it's got money the viewership
yeah the viewership and the money and
and if you keep it at that that's
understandable people will still like
you they'll still respect you but
you have to
you have to you have to state that
though it's believe it or not forte
there's a lot of people
that i've resp
that it's just interesting how some
people are very extra with it and then
some people understand you got to get
that bag man we understand like we ain't
going to get them that's why like i
never understood people that go after
ads in videos because it's like look
like it's as long as they're transparent
if they use the program i don't believe
in content creators that come out there
and they act like they use the product
but they don't but if you want to buy a
15 20 second slot in a video for that
person to show that brand that's that
that product to their to their
viewership i personally don't see a
problem with that
i don't either
and it's like you know that that's why
you know we gotta
i i do say that you know i do hold the
the reviewers some liable for this
because i do feel like they're not being
transparent they're not telling people
that they didn't beat these games but i
do understand that their dilemma when
it's like look we don't have the time
or the you know
three four days to beat an 80-hour game
is ridiculous
but at that point these places like ign
and stuff they should say we're not
reviewing your games at all
until you
restructure the way you do things
because some of these games will be gold
for weeks and weeks
and they don't send them out to
reviewers it's because they have these
devs crunching up to the last minute to
get those day one patches out and until
we come out and be very vocal and say we
are done with this we are not reviewing
your games until you get that out we're
not covering your games sure it will
cost money it will it'll cost all these
reviewers all these
websites money but i think the end
result would be
these publishers like bam namco that
made that's publishing eldon ring
they'll be like look
we got to do better because they are on
our ass over this stuff and that's why i
say about the bugs you know we'll
translate into the bugs a little bit
like
the way that these games are releasing
is unacceptable and we keep buying them
me myself included you know i think
content craze are a little bit different
because you know we got to cover these
games even if they're broken but you
know it's even on us because we
shouldn't do it
the same thing but it's like man i'm not
but the thing is i don't want to blame
the consumers i've always felt like
it needs we need to be one of those
things where it's like
look you can't you are taking advantage
of our passion
it is not my fault your game's broken i
did what i was supposed to do i handed
you the 60 70 bucks it's your fault it's
your job to make sure that game is
functioning when i play it on my end and
that's why i'm always like oh don't
pre-order no pre-order because my guns
are always going to be aimed at the
people selling the games not the people
that is playing the games because
they're the ones that's going to do it
just because they made a transition of
money does not give people the right to
tell them what to do with their cash we
need to tell the people that are low-key
scheming people out of money
and some of these things won't be fixed
for months and the game is useless
yeah man you you hit it right on the
head brother it's um
it's a mentality that
developers know
um shout out to what's up playstation
barry and uh persona when they had sean
layton on
sean layton even said it on there that
people
don't beat like you talking about going
about beating games and stuff about
developers they talk about just
consumers beating games he's like yeah
people aren't beating games so you don't
if sean layton knows that you don't
think these publishers know that you
don't think that you know if they know
you're not even finishing games they
probably thinking like well shoot they
we didn't gotta even
have the game ready day one because most
of the people out here just gonna just
experience half the game and then
they're done with it you know so
it's just it's a nasty cycle and like
you said i'm never going to put
ownership or blame on the consumer side
of it
but
it literally does come down to
you have to vote with your wallet
you know cyberpunk sold 13 million
with
people returning the game
at a massive level
we don't know what it ended up selling
by the time it was over all i know is
after they after they told everybody
that hey you can go to whatever retailer
you bought it at and return it
when they put out their financial
numbers for that for the initial launch
of cyberpunk which was like a week after
launch or something they sold 13 million
copies still did fantastic they still
did and then and guess what now that
they and i and i did they run it back to
the bank laughing look at you suckers
and this is the funny thing i was at
work yesterday and a customer was
looking for a copy of cyberpunk because
he knows the next gen patch came out
guess what
literally three months ago
i couldn't give a cyberpunk i had like
probably 20 or 30 copies of the day i
looked in my store and i looked across
pretty much our entire district
not one copy new or used so guess what
people have forgiven they just gone out
and bought the the the the game again
because the new deals not dlc but the
new update is out and that's just how
consumers are we're very we're very
fickle we love what we love
gaming is a hobby to us and we
understand that and if we want to play
it we're going to play it but let's be
for real these companies they know that
too
and as long as we keep going in the
direction we're going in
we're asking for them to basically just
say oh one more time please one more
time please and that's just going to be
the consistent cycle
yeah i feel like
the money thing is good like you know
vote with your wallet but i think voting
with your voice is more effective
especially if more people are doing it i
don't think people realize how powerful
social media is like if you respectfully
give these people your mind on twitter
and you see
like you know what's more effective to
me is money that they may or may not see
because the game's not out now or a
community manager logging into 100 plus
notifications every five minutes
you know oh yeah that's everything that
gets them man you know it's like at the
end of the day that's very subjective
because if they make enough money
they're not gonna give two shits what's
going on twitter if they make enough
money to justify what's going on but the
thing is people don't realize that it's
not just the money in your wallet that
matters it's their stock going down
because they're being attacked on social
media like crazy there's multiple ways
of getting the point across and we've
seen with cyberpunk that
cyberpunk we saw it with battlefield we
saw it with uh battlefront we saw it
with xbox when they were doing the the
xbox live thing you are voi if p if
enough people get behind something you
can make these multi-billion trillion
dollar companies fold in an afternoon
and the law and the amount of time it
takes to watch a lord of the rings movie
you can photo multi-trillion dollar
company
you can
alright
let's move on to our favorite thing
destiny to the witch queen man okay for
all you that know man
all you that know attic show wasn't here
last week man i had i had a severe case
of destiny is a severe cave such a case
that
the game's still playing on my tv i'm
just not playing it you i don't know if
you guys have heard like the orbit music
but my tv is like really low so i don't
think you're hearing that you might hear
that i don't know congratulations you
get some kind of background noise but
i had destiny itis man
it took about two to three days to get
away from it man but now i'm better i'm
better i'm feeling good you know my
temperature's down and you know
me and forte we have a good amount of
hours in this game i mean orbeez too as
you can see
you see we have a good amount of sitting
in orbit
it's crazy oh man uh i'm uh 1549 or
something like that now so
you know we have a good amount of time
into destiny uh
what's your first impressions been
uh
by far the best dlc
that they've
i feel like that
bungie has made in probably the last
15 10 years 10 to 15 years
i think
you know i won't say 15. apparently
that's 10 years because i think halo
reach was amazing halo reach i i think
was probably the best and the strongest
of the halo campaigns and it didn't have
master chief available in it but
destiny definitely the best
taking king was by far my favorite dlc
because it it ended with
one of the best raids i felt like in
destiny history which was you know
king's fall
now
just on the strength of what we played
so far in this dlc
campaign-wise amazing now can i put it
above taking king when it comes to the
whole package not i can't yet because i
got to see the raid i got to see the
raid
i got to see the raid if the but if the
raid comes anywhere near what this
campaign was oh yeah i'm i'm there 100
there i think they
hit it out the park i think the extra as
much as it killed us destiny fans
i think the extra three to four months
truly helped i think this is what
happens when you see
a company or a publisher take a singular
mind
and say this is what we want to do with
our game
and and they took a lot of community
feedback when it comes to the things
that they want the community wanted them
to do which a lot of people really give
bungie a hard time for sometimes
i think crafting is really good i think
it's very convoluted i do think it takes
a while to do some of the stuff in the
game that you want to do
but it's new
so i have faith that over the course of
the season they're gonna fix a lot of
that stuff and make it a little bit
easier to craft and get the material you
need to do that but just talking about
the story
adding legendary campaign to it
respecting your grind shout out to the
ash and luca she's not even playing
dusty she got the 5 what 15 31 in the
first couple of days and she's been off
playing elder ring because she feels
like she's high enough light she's
already raped ready she's already at
what the raid level can be just to start
the raid if she wanted to do it
but she's able to leave the game and go
play elder ring and put 50 hours into
that
and enjoy yourself somewhere else if you
want to and that's been kind of the
problem with destiny over the course of
the years and stuff you felt like it was
a job
and it kind of was now
i didn't i don't have to log in and play
i'm pretty good i'm good for saturday
when we do our raid day one but i enjoy
the game so much it just makes me want
to keep coming back and playing it and i
only touched probably a quarter of the
game i have haven't done any raid since
the new season started i just did pvp
for the first time yesterday doing
pinnacles and stuff my first nightfall
this season was with you last night
i didn't do any night flaws until i did
the one with you last night
so
i i'm enjoying the game and i'm only
doing a quarter of the stuff i was doing
before but i i feel fulfilled and that's
something that i can't honestly say
wasn't the thing over the course of the
last couple of years when it comes to
like destiny
i agree i i think that
this is by far the best that they've
ever done
um i do i'm still
a little bit on and i'm talking about in
terms of uh taking uh in destiny 2
destiny 1
and as far as all destiny i still think
uh you know the taking king is still a
little bit above it now
as long as the raid's good then i will
give that to which queen if the raid is
it don't even have to be as good as
taking king because damn that raid was
good
yeah this has got to be really good
that's awesome really good i feel like i
couldn't really expect much difference
from that rate like that's how good that
raid was but as long as this raid's
solid and it's a really good experience
because i do think the witch queen
story's better by far it's way by far
better but it's just like man that
rank is so important right now so much
falls on that right i think so much
falls on that raid that there's this
really cheesy
like exploit people are using with chest
that they didn't even worry about that
they like do the chest grinding that's
fine we gonna make sure this raid fine
we ain't diverting no resources from
this raid
nope i agree 100
i think um in general it just comes back
to
what have they done to make this game a
better experience i think the new player
experience
is uh or the returning not the new play
because the new player spirit still is
crazy we people that haven't played
destiny forever probably don't know what
the heck is going on but for people
that's returning like you or uh shout
out to you know anybody else coming back
they put you at
the same light level
as a person that's been grinding this
game for over seven years
literally everybody started at the same
point 1350 you were campaign ready for
legendary at 13.50 you just had to make
the decision do i want to go in and do
it at legendary and then if you did do
it they respected your grind so much
that we gonna give you 20 free levels of
powerful
levels which would usually take a normal
person that's not me or addict maybe an
extra week week and a half to get
through and as if they're playing
consistently every day
you know that was a huge
that was a huge olive branch that they
gave everybody so
it all just it all basically just comes
down to this saturday when we do the
raid like how is this story going to
finish and the funny thing is we're on
this long arc right now where there's a
um there's a quest line that takes 28
steps that won't be even finished after
this season i feel like they have a uh
dreaming city little reveal coming up
where a lot of stuff in the game is
gonna change i don't think we're gonna
get like a new destination like how the
dreamy city like transformed through a
cycle and everything like that but i do
know there's i do think there's going to
be something that's going to happen
after the raid that the raid is going to
influence
to in order to open up so we can have
more stuff to do that we haven't even
seen yet how much you want to bet that
when we finish this raid
something's gonna happen it's gonna
break the curse on the dreaming city
yeah because that's why the dreamy
city's still here
people
i always wondered like i was wondering
like why are you leaving the dream city
i understand you know with the whole
south with home marisol and the queen
and the awokens and everything and you
kind of want to leave that
world still there
but it didn't you know shatters throne
is still there
but yeah what happens if that does open
up and we literally stopped the
three-week curse on that because at a
certain point that is like the only
thing that's kind of been lingering
since um
since some destiny um
says destiny's been a thing that would
be interesting if if we ended the raid
and
like once if the the raid boss is sap is
is like the ghost
you know
yeah the the the ghost the from the
start if you know what i'm talking about
yeah i was i was thinking that
you know what's funny why wasn't
sabaton's the right boss so we just
don't know it
yeah i i think a lot of people were
shocked when you saw oryx
in king's fall
like you killed his um shadow or he's
taken ver take himself
inside the campaign but then you fought
like real oryx at the end yeah the only
way to kill a taking god is to go into
their ascended realm and kill them there
exactly they're immortal outside like
they just pretty much regenerate after a
certain amount of time but you know we
won't stick too much into the destiny 2
which queen but uh for anyone that i saw
someone in the chat saying they need to
be better on newer players i think
they're doing better but i do think they
need to improve a little bit more i i
think they're being better as well as on
us as players making sure that we have
good experiences and then you have good
experiences too that's always been their
problem they can't have a good balance a
good center ground where
we're going to keep the hardcore
audience happy and we're going to keep
the casual audience happy and i think
that's always been their issue all right
let's go into
the the main event of the evening
elden ring vs horizon forbidden west all
right now for those of you that's been
living under the rock because i'm sure
most of you that's in the chat has been
seeing what's going on twitter
twitter is a battlefield right now and
it's
a lot of xbox people because they're
they're using elden ring a multi-player
as their lance which is funny and then
you got the the souls so pretty much how
it is like a three-way war you got the
xbox people the souls people versus the
playstation fanboy people
it was funny because it's like they're
comparing games that should not be
compared uh they're uh a lot of people
are angry over review scores because
eldon ring is a 97 which i don't think
people realize
how much stuff has to go down for a game
to get a 97 on metacritic like i
expected like a beginning 91 you know 91
92
97 is up there with like the legend of
zelda breath uh uh breath of the wild
with the legend of zelda ocarina of time
which is considered like one of the best
games ever let look you go ahead and
give your opinion on this one little
deal i'm gonna look up
all the metacritic score for that high
yeah that's a pretty high ones man but
the funny thing to me is you got so many
people
[Music]
on just different platforms talking
about something that they most likely
aren't even going to play now i do think
a lot of people were influenced by that
97 overall metacritic because
i see people that never
even tried the souls game you know
at least in my case like i haven't beat
any of them but i tried the majority of
them it just never stuck with me i know
people that literally went to the stores
i want to try out elder ring i said have
you ever played a souls game before do
you know what they're like you're super
hard and there's a lot of stuff that is
involved with them and they say oh man
no i just want to try it because it
looks so good i said what did you see
the review said yeah the review was like
a 97 overall and i was like yeah i said
you might want to do a little research
i'm not going to stop nobody from buying
the game if they want to play it so a
lot of people you know bought this game
and went out and did their thing
but i do think it's just the fact that a
lot of people inside this are just
community
like let's if we want to put it on xbox
you know xbox people we're talking about
well our game is you know running better
because of vrr because we got very
refresh rates and stuff where
playstation you got to play on a
playstation 4 pro version to get the
better version of the game then you got
souls people out here talking about how
everybody out here is trying to gain you
know i shout out the uh actually looking
she said the worst thing that probably
could happen to this game is to get into
97 because now a lot of people feel like
they want to they it's like more
opinionated on game that none of these
people ever wanted to play in the first
place but now they feel like they have
to play because square i swear from has
basically ascended into another
stratosphere when it comes to um just
games in general you know most of the
dark souls games fall anywhere in that
89 to 92
which is really really good but when you
hit 97
that's like halo combat evolved and in
ocarina of time breath of the wild
that's
that's that's that's up there and i
think that's the thing
that people are really really talking
about there compared to
some people on playstation think that
horizon is scored super low and
we got developed we got uh publications
after giving it 6.5
by and saying that the last game was
this game is way better than the old
game
and uh it's just it's kind of a
disconnect but people are just using
this is another list war in my opinion
but the biggest thing for me adding
definitely
yeah what what is your biggest takeaway
from just
the three-sided war that we've been
experiencing over the last couple of
days
i feel like that
these games are different but i
understand people's like look there's
bugs in in an elden ring there's bugs in
horizon
but they feel like eldon ring is getting
passes on that and i do agree to some
point eldon ring does have like a three
to four point curve and i think that's
mainly because a lot of like souls fans
are reviewing eldon ring and not
necessarily anyone so you're obviously
going to get that like higher curve uh
but we can't act like there's not a lot
of playstation people reviewing uh
horizon either i'm sure there's a lot of
playstation people reviewing horizon so
look what i want to do is show you how
ridiculous
this metacritic score thing is here on
the screen you have
the all-time best games on metacritic
number ones legend of zelda arc or
anytime of a 99
that means like one person reviewed this
just a little bit lower than everyone
else you got tony hawk pro skater 2
a skating game with a 98
yeah let's take a moment to realize
that it's a 98 a skating game that was
in 2000 look i'm not saying this game
isn't it isn't phenomenal i'm not saying
it's a fun game but i'm saying can you
really on the same scale compare games
like tony hawk pro skater 2 to a game
like eldon ring and horizon forbidden
west i don't think he can
but it was reviewed the way it was and
he got the metacritic score the way it
was then you got grand theft auto 4
perfectly
reasonable for this game to be there i
don't think this game deserves to be
that high i think it's actually one of
the worst grand theft autos in my
opinion i didn't like it too much but i
understand why people do like it
so i got a five dollar super chat from
mangango mcthickney thickens
er is a good game i think the zealots
are upset that uh horizon forbidden mess
forbidden mess
forgotten mess forgotten this is exactly
that a fart in the window i think it's a
good game
oh my god that is so funny
i will i will let me say something to
that i will i agree with that one part
right there
i think a lot of playstation fans are a
little upset
that not only
not only is this game getting passed
over
but it's literally being forgotten in a
week
for the second time and you know what
but whose fault is that really is that
elder ring's fault no no no no it's not
the reason was it was it was it zelda
was it nintendo's fault for breath for a
while liter like it was i forget who did
it it was on our show someone literally
tweeted like that tweeted somebody put a
super chat saying so when horizon when
horizon 3 comes out what's going to be
the next 97 overall metacritic game
that's going to release within a week of
it it's going to be elder scrolls 5.
microsoft if any of you watching this
podcast i know okay
man go over there and talk to bethesda
software studio because look
i just want to see it again like
you know i really would just want to see
if sony has the balls to put this game
its sequel out in the same week of her
uh
as elder scrolls six do you think they
would do something like that
no because i think microsoft is still
keying on releasing games during the
holidays where sony refuses to do it now
and that's why i don't think god of war
is coming out this year because i don't
think they're going to really i don't
think they're going to release do you
think it's coming out this year got
awards
next year early next year i said the
same thing everybody said who's coming
out there and what's funny is i said the
same thing about horizon last year
remember i was like it's like i didn't
tell you it's not coming out this year
oh i don't know about that and then what
happens it gets delayed
yep hey uh
grace will you get rid of uh that webcam
hot girls in chat i'll get rid of it now
but if they come back uh
no don't delete their messages when
people come in there's some nonsense
like that you gotta you gotta get rid of
them like straight up get rid of them
there's no no go no collect two hundred
dollars they out of here all right so
let's go let's move down
so then we got another
copy of gta4
and then we got
soul calibur a head-to-head fighting
game
that's good man so caliber was good then
we go down super mario galaxy deserve
this i don't know if it's a 97 but it
definitely deserved to be on this list
somewhere
super mario galaxy 2 somehow got the
exact same score as the other one i
didn't realize uh red dead redemption 2
got a higher score
yes
that's crazy
red dead is freaking beautiful that game
is beautiful game is trash i mean listen
you might want to talk about how bad the
amy in that game is but when you when
you walk around in that world you see
people getting pulled by horse carriage
by by hooking ladders like oh yeah this
is a this is a true
western game i mean yo i was seeing uh
some big giant creatures pulling some uh
some
some cat uh some carts and stuff in
eldon
ring you didn't see that
that's why it's 97 overall
all right so then we got two copies of
gta 5
97 each which i bet you if i look at
this they don't even have a whole lot of
reviewers 14 reviewers
well that breath that um
that i created time only had 20 i
believe 20 or 20 50 reviewers that's a
little bit better hold up let's see
i think it was 22 for ocarina 22 22
reviewers but you know what that was
awesome
but that was also print back then there
was really no internet
i feel like you're my honest opinion
forte we need to get rid of all the
reviews and start fresh
i i think we need to have a reset button
a nuke button uh a a can't pass go
button man because i feel like
metacritic in itself needs to be
restructured like the whole damn website
but it is what it is and i'm not saying
none of these games are bad i am saying
gta 4 is bad though i am saying that but
none of these games are like bad it's
just i do feel like like
two two decades ago reviewing standards
are not the same anymore
so i feel like
it's kind like you're never you're
really gonna get games up here in this
caliber now ever rarely
because more people are reviewing games
how many people review tony hawk
19
19.
now let's see how many people reviewed
eldon ring to get a similar score
like 90 something
legitimate like actual websites not just
yeah yeah
okay then we gotta find all this out
from don otaku horizon one was already
scored too high it was a low 80s i'mma
be honest especially after breath of the
wild but forbidden west is a range of
what it deserves i i actually agree with
that i do think that the first horizon
was given a crazy curve and the reason
people are seeing like this
inconsistency with the what the
the the metacritic scores on the sequel
considering it does everything better is
because the original one i don't think
deserved that high
but i digress it's not none of my
business i i i i just that's what i do
when people talk about some
hide hi i don't talk about
all right so then we got breath of the
wild with a 97. so breath of the wild
you know you know what if anything from
this forte you know what i hope
i hope we get more people that are
comparing every game to eldon ring and
not breath of the wild can we leave
breath of the wild in 2017. can we
please compare other games to other
other games we don't got to compare
everything to breath in the wild until
breath of the wild too comes out
yeah
which would we gave it a year this year
if it really is breath of the wild had
to go through 109 reviewers to earn its
97 compared to its predecessor legend of
zelda ocarina of time that only had at
least 22 people
22 people man
times have changed
i gotta please more people
when i do a podcast than these people
had to do reviewing
if you look at those reviews the funny
thing is
how you can it always seems like the
nintendo reviews have way more reviews
because way more people play nintendo
games
than playstation or xbox like i i don't
like you say how many people reviewed um
horizon
um
horizon
yeah how many people reviewed that uh i
had to go way down
it's down the list it's this far
but no just
dude i went to page three that's so
right here we still in the 90s let's go
to page seven okay now we finally
hitting the 89s
oh my god page seven there's a lot of
90s man
a lot of games here the original dark
souls was at 89. they've always reviewed
very well yeah that's it they they
always did 89 to 92.
that's why as soon as people saw that
90s i was on the phone with luca when
that 97 hit and she was like yo
elderly hit 97 115
reviews
oh for uh horizon horizon forbidden west
had to say oh that's a lot of reviews to
get that's my god
yeah that's a lot
that's more than i thought would have
reviewed it but like i think i think a
lot of reviewers are it's a lot of
review sites now
uh internet becomes a big part of it
uh compared to
print back in the night like in the
early 90s if you look at it besides like
these remakes like red dead redemption 2
perfect art
on the n64 tony pro tony hawk on the ps2
breath of the wild is concurrent and
then we got the dreamcast on the 2000s
uh we got
if you look up you got this game on the
dreamcast
this game on the ps3 this game on the
original playstation this game on the
n64
you got boulders gate from the 2000s you
got san andreas which i actually think
san andreas deserved that score like
that was a great game that's my favorite
um my favorite game uh by gta standards
and then you got the legendary
collection i used to have this i
remember i i got one of these
this legend of zelda collector's edition
and you got like look how old these
games are like
legend of zelda
look legend of zelda be killing it with
these reviews man
like we have almost every legend of
zelda within a three metacritic score
range
95 96 97 we got to find out super chat
from donna talking it's not that
nintendo games get more reviews but
y'all were only looking at the
playstation 5 reviews of elgin ring
without adding the pc and xbox ones i
agree with that
uh only really registered one standard
thing
um that's true that's true persona five
ninety five uh i wonder how many people
reviewed that 71 that's actually pretty
good 71 people reviewed that game look
regardless how it goes
all the more of the story
it stopped giving so much energy
into these metacritic scores because as
we've shown you
half these metacritic scores are
probably older than some of you in the
chat
it's just like look like standards have
changed a lot of these games if you re
reveal let's remaster man 95
where is it where'd you see it
it was up you passed it oh bioshock got
a 94 overall man i mean yeah my effort
it was what was my bag i love that the
more of the story is review standards
have changed if you remade some of these
games and have them be reviewed as they
are just in newer graphics a lot of
these games ain't getting these scores a
lot of them are i'm sure you the zeldas
probably would because i do think
zelda's
is a formula that sticks regardless how
much time goes by but i mean look at
this mad
nfl 2003 on the ps2 got a 95
come on man
i know that was the first year that they
asked stadium lighting that's why screw
that i don't care the game the game
looked phenomenal i don't i don't care
if it's holographic it's a sports game
hello that's all i'm saying man like you
know we got to be better on this look
when you want like i bring up metacritic
score because i don't like the way that
the reviewing process is done i don't
like the way that some people
overlook other stuff but other companies
they they they hold them accountable for
everything they do but as far as the
scores themselves it is how it is
um i you know i i brought up
i brought up in the past that you know
what
what this is good for is like you know i
see last of us back in 2013
and i say yo that's a 95.
that that's actually good
and then what you're supposed to do
is you're supposed to click the button
and go in here and read the reviews of
why this 95 was accomplished but guess
what people stop at this part right here
saying they got a 95 they see this and
the first thing they do is forte we
going to twitter like
like what they say
it is what it is man what how do you
feel needs to be done with this uh you
know review process
um
we need to get rid of okay so it will
never happen but they need to get rid of
the actual number like get back to like
i don't yeah like i i i suggest if you
buy it or not that's as far as i'll go
yeah like i said you do not buy it i
think that is the the number one thing
that people should start
you know gravitating to you know because
reviews are opinionated pieces in their
you know just in right
so why are you putting a score on
something that is completely different
from what another person might
experience so it should just come down
do i recommend this game well did i have
fun with it yes did i did i think the
game had some issues where you know
things would pop up yes but it still
doesn't change the fact that it didn't
change my enjoyment of the game and i
enjoyed it so i think that's where we
need to start at because i think the
number
is the biggest flexibility of what's
going on inside the community if a gang
didn't have a number on it and a person
just says oh i i really like this game
and i recommend you try it
then
that then where's the argument gonna
happen then i guess people will say well
this person said i respect his opinion
more than this person it will still be
the same thing but at least number wise
it wouldn't be like trying to like put
giants against other giants and stuff
well did you just play the game and it's
your opinion at that point
yeah and i think the biggest thing that
you really need to look at too man we we
got uh shout out to eight eight eight
months uh by bunty
uh monty enough respect to destiny
players and friends but with over 7 000
hours in destiny i have to give it a
break i'm still not coming back yet
forte i totally understand that respect
that man that's how it is man uh i i was
the same way i took what a year pretty
much i only came on for certain things
and you could ask for i'm well known in
the clan for doing [ __ ] in the last two
weeks of the of the season that's why i
was shocked that he's still playing
right now but you know
all i got to say man is like let's just
change stuff up and for the people you
know what's funny playstation fanboys
are attacking everyone because horizon
didn't get the review score that they
feel like it should have got and i'm
just like you got both games on your
platform you won
like
it is what it is man so you know
is there any last statements that you
have in terms of this horizon forbidden
did you first off did you play odin ring
did uh
i have it installed on my thing i'm not
starting that game i refuse to start it
until after this raid is over
yeah i've been trying to balance it a
little bit like i don't can't do it i've
been trying to review a little bit
better in terms of like just reviewing
in general uh so i'm going to
go into that a little bit
it's just like at the end of the day i
do feel like
i want to i want to stream man i really
do i enjoy streaming i'm going to try to
get better at it because streaming is a
skill don't let people lie to you
streaming is a skill that you gotta hone
and get better at i feel like it's
easier for me to stream something like
eldon ring so maybe as much as i want to
blaze it trust me you guys yesterday i
went around the world just activating
graces and what's funny is my
girlfriend's name is grace
and i was talking to kid smooth and i
was like yeah right there get that grace
and she's like what and i'm like oh no
the grace on the game not the grace in
real life but you know it's just the
game is phenomenal i have to put it out
there now i'm probably not going to
review it because the the amount of
drastic things that you have to do to
play that game and i don't have the time
to really sit down and play that because
i got the destiny thing uh i am going to
be reviewing the um that game for
nintendo switch coming out friday so
look out for this channel friday i'll
probably stream uh you know
probably two hour two and a half hours
of it depending on how much i'm feeling
it but then i'll
review it and probably strain the rest
on twitch but
my thing that i really enjoy is just
when you're going around in that horse
forte on eldon ring
yeah it's just so special like i can't
describe to you like when people feel
like oh this is just another open world
game this is not just another open world
game this is one of the best open world
games that's out there when you're going
around it feels like the world's alive
sure there's not like a lot of npcs
going on yes triangle strategy i will be
reviewing that friday stream going on 5
p.m we're going back to the conversation
when you're going around this world it
feels like you're part of it and i don't
give this to too many games
but this is a skyrim field type of world
where sometimes i'll be going through
the world and i come across a random
boss out of nowhere and
previous from software games you had to
get down and deal with that smoke you
know what i'm saying you had to kill
that boss but now it's just like yo i
don't have to deal with you fam and you
just keep gulping away from him like
that's what i appreciate from something
you come across giant
giant creatures that are out of nowhere
uh i saw people on tick tock coming
across like dragons the size of like
three or four buildings that's just
sleeping no out of nowhere they're just
sleeping
it's just it's so
nice
the amount of time and detail they spent
into eldon ring and i'm gonna be honest
with you guys
sony should never have looked at eldon
ring
and felt like a week was enough time to
separate them from elder it wasn't even
a week it was like a couple days
yeah right and it's just like look
i feel bad for gorilla because i feel
like sony
should have pushed that game back
or try to get that game out a month
before this game came out because
i'm playing this game
and that's no surprise to me
that this game took all the shine away
from horizon forbidden west none
whatsoever
but anyway man that's that's pretty much
the show wasn't a lot to talk about this
week uh i apologize for missing last
week i told you you guys are gonna be
more consistent but i've always been the
standpoint that like
if it comes to something that really
really means a lot to me in games
i'm getting too old man i'm going to
play that [ __ ]
that's why you know it doesn't happen
often because most games i can wait for
i'm not really that but i was waiting
for the witch queen we've been waiting
for that i've been waiting for sabbathum
for three years
so my ass was playing sabbath and what's
funny is i was playing with king and
them i still stream that day on the
channel was streamed uh taking key uh i
streamed the witch queen day one
definitely go watch that and i'm sitting
here and i'm looking at the time it's
like 3 30 4 o'clock you know i'm sitting
here thinking myself
do i really want to pl to do a podcast
today
absolutely not went straight to twitter
told you know i had destiny itis man
sometimes you get sick you got you gotta
you gotta rest man you gotta rest and
the way i fixed that was playing
destiny to the witch queen but
anyway gaming forte man
what has been going on what what you got
popping man i know you got something
going on tell tell the realm what you
got caught popping oh man i got a lot of
stuff going on man got some videos in
the pipeline you know check out the
channel gaming forte youtube twitter
xbox live playstation check it out if
you like destiny content you like xbox
content we pretty much you know just
gaming in general uh so i got some
videos around destiny some stuff going
on in the game got some xbox stuff
coming out over the course of the next
couple of days we also have dps podcast
which is every thursday
at 9 00 p.m this week it will be on my
channel last week it was on slo-mo's
channel so
you know some of you guys in the chat i
see you there all the time but uh truly
appreciate um all of you guys and um
enjoy the games that you're playing if
it's
if it's horizon or
if it's
elden ring if if you could play elder
ring because sometimes it doesn't work
for people uh or if you're just playing
any other game just enjoy what you're
doing right now and um we'll see you
guys at the next show and keep in mind
you playstation fans you can play elder
ring and horizon for ben west right so
you win it you win man you don't need to
be on twitter
you don't need to be in spaces you don't
need to be doing none of that stuff man
you need to have that white
blunt object that you could kill people
behind forte that's huge then i'm pretty
sure he can he can get a workout just by
curling that thing
all you have is that man that's all you
need but you know i appreciate it for
coming through here man we're going to
go ahead and end this going to got some
got some surprises for you iop related
addiction really we got stuff going all
year round man trying to get some good
guests on you man we're trying to do the
best that we can be but until next time
this is gaming forte and lord at it and
we out peace